[Music]
London in the 1960s everyone had a story
about race I come here for a proper
Street after rolling pick the pipe near
Cape rich do I mind if I fight that way
yeah these are the Kray twins
[Music]
you take my breath away you must be
Frances she figure we look alike do you
like being a gangster I like the money
and the respect your brother Rob is a
violent and psychopathic he's off his
rocker you talking about be gangsters
which is what we are the Mafia's made
inquiries London is going to be the Las
Vegas of Europe you can handle it you
come to Philadelphia you should nice
Italian girl we're good a foot
I prefer boys it's a dudes sometimes
great but I am NOT prejudiced you got a
lot of balls amid that case
yeah my proper we're gonna rule
they don't laugh your diarrhea how you
might do something about rock I'll
contact
[Music]
he's my brother I wanna live like this
she knows too many things pass we're
going down into the sewer
after the craze my lucky for my brother
is how I measured myself what about your
loyalty to me crime is still a business
you don't want a war yeah
listen to yourself one if not blood is
thicker than water
[Music]
you won't find anything a lot in
themselves you
[Music]
our world is fire and blood
[Music]
everybody's gone out of their mind
you're not the only hoarder max out here
everything hurts you want to get through
this
[Music]
do as I say
now pick up what you can
[Music]
oh what a day what a lovely day
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for bringing us collectively
to this moment it is a moment but so
many have dreamed of claiming history
starts today
[Music]
guy whoever is the evil person I don't
work for him my friend works better are
you gonna behave yourself tomorrow I
told you more than my job I'm a reporter
I follow people that do not want to be
followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people you tell me
Joe finish mr. brahs is that a threat we
had to learn how to hide in plain sight
I'm pretty good at it for you
you suck whoever you are I work at the
Life Foundation and it needs your help
we found something we call them
symbiosis Carleton Drake believes that
the union between human and symbiote is
the key to our evolution
I'm feeling really sick
I'm here boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people when I see it
and do whatever we want do we have a
deal
really just a quick question
one thing you almost did
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
our feet
there's a storm coming
[Music]
you sound like you're looking forward to
it I'm adaptable what are you I'm
Gotham's reckoning
[Music]
did they kill him I'm not sure huh
why didn't you just tell me your
punishment must be more severe
[Music]
I don't know
how'd you run they you should be as
afraid of him as
I won't marry you
I've heard enough members of the Wayne
family
oh these people and he
you've given them
another warned me about getting into
cars with strange mark that's just me
already
[Music]
see
the enemy tanks have stopped why why
waste precious tanks when they can pick
us off on the air like fish in a barrel
there are 400,000 men on this Beach
[Music]
[Music]
it's coming back round where we going
Dunkirk
okay
there's no hiding from this Sun we have
a job to do if we go there was I
[Music]
[Music]
you can practically see it from here
what about if I go for an hour
[Music]
you know what the difference is between
Adolf Hitler now Capone it was dead
Capone was like a king in Florida he has
full-blown dementia I have a reason to
believe I could all be an elaborate Act
what's this about we have information
that your client may have tucked away a
very large sum of money and drop it
[Music]
[Music]
guys like you on this place ten million
dollars
if you can get him to talk
go on rampage
we made a promise someday we was going
to make it big
the only thing that really matters is
how magics family there's one thing you
should know about me I specialize in a
very specific type of security
subconscious security you're talking
about dreams
[Music]
mr. Cobb has a job offer he would like
to discuss with you we can work
placement
not exactly we create the world of the
dream we bring the subject into that
dream and they fill it with their
secrets then you break it and still it
well it's not strictly speaking leaving
it's called inception
already
and this last job
feel real while we're in them it's only
when we wake up that we realize
something was actually strange
you're not prepared
[Music]
dreams classic
I have it under control
I need to see out of control mustn't be
afraid to dream with a bigger darling
I've been authorized to offer you
promotion demikhov in the new state
security you will have a great life
if you do as you're told I had to tell
you this son died of a tragic accident
it was a lie my boy was murdered
murder is strictly a capitalist disease
you're flirting with reason the man that
killed my son he's still out there
you know what people get around here
when they don't want the truth they get
better enjoy your new life
you win with the most go anymore if you
do anything which on the minds of my
authority I would kill myself
there's been another one same cause of
death did you say any more he won't you
QA head right now what do you want me I
would like to stop coming there's a
witness
well you're going to find his job and we
find him
Kilis man can you do that
you do know what every snow
you